قالت منظمه الصحه العالميه ان الوضع
الصحيه في غزه لا يمكن تصوره وان شمال
القطاع اصبح بلا مستشفيات عامله ودعت
المنظمه الى وقف فوري لاطلاق النار
وتمكينها والمنظمات الاخرى من دعم
المستشفيات في
غزه تامل منظمه الصحه العالميه من التمكن
من ادخال الوقود في الايام المقبله لدعم
المستشفيات التي توقفت عن العمل كليا او
جزئيا خصوصا في شمال غزه لكن ما نحتاج
اليه فعليا هو وقف لاطلاق النار لا يمكن
تحمل رؤيه اناس يفترض انهم في اماكن امنه
ويحصلون على الرعايه واصبحوا الان ضحايا
يجلسون انتظارا للموت ينبغي ضمان التنقل
الامن في قطاع غزه وتامين المستلزمات
الطبيه الناس هنا يموتون جوعا وعطشا انها
معاناه لا يمكن تصورها لم ارى شيئا كهذا
من قبل على الامم المتحده ومنظمه الصحه
العالميه التصرف بشكل ملح لوضع حد لموت
المسنين والنساء
والاطفال